I think a lot of young people today they
think about money but the economy in
America isn't it's not really about
money money represents value and value
is of course how we measure wealth and
wealth is something that is created when
we work when we make things you know
people are Googling like how do I start
a business what they really are looking
for is how do I make money without
leaving my bed or putting my phone down
and they're eager to get money to buy
things but they're not eager to do the
things that create value that the money
represents there was an interesting
study that came out this year comparing
like what's going on in the Ukraine war
comparing America to Russia and it
talked about how we have no productive
sector we don't make anything our
industry our agriculture our
manufacturing construction it's 15 of
our economy the rest of services